mega razzia im morgengrauen noch heute
morgen durchsuchten 800 polizisten 61
objekte deutschlandweit ist es eine
kampfansage gegen die gefährlichsten
rechtsextremen terrorgruppen in
deutschland
die atomwaffen division die
gefährlichsten neonazi-gruppe der welt
sie wollen den weltweiten rassenkrieg
seit 2008 zehn ist die rechtsextreme
terrorgruppe in deutschland aktiv doch
jetzt schlägt er rechts stark zurück 800
polizisten elf bundesländer ein ziel im
visier der ermittler die gefährlichsten
neonazi gruppen deutschlands combat tae
jin knockout fünf jahren atomwaffen
division es ist die größte neonazi
razzia seit ende des zweiten weltkriegs
offenbar erfolgreich laut
generalbundesanwaltschaft nehmen die
ermittler unter anderem ein mitglied der
berüchtigten atomwaffen division fest
und uns zugeschaltet ist jetzt bei
chefreporter und polizei experte frank
schneider frank atomwaffen division wie
viele mitglieder sind in dieser gruppe
wer steckt dahinter
vielleicht muss man einmal ganz kurz
erklären diese atomwaffen division kommt
aus den usa war dort 2015 bis 2020
bekannt als extrem gefährliche
rechtsextreme zelle und gegründet von
einem 70 jährigen neonazi und den usa
sind auch fünf morde passiert durch den
großen fan auf druck des fps hat sich
diese gruppe angeblich aufgelöst in
deutschland tauchte sie vor vier jahren
zum ersten mal auf und hat in
deutschland jedenfalls nachweislich noch
keine schweren straftaten begangen aber
wird eben ja sage ich mal nachwuchs
terroristen das ist der sinn dahinter
man will die öffentliche ordnung
zerstöre man will einen rasten einen
bürgerkrieg und will durch dieses
destabilisieren der öffentlichen ordnung
mehr oder weniger den tag so nennt man
das immer herbeiführen und will dann
mehr oder weniger das ganze land mit
festen strukturen übernehmen man will
halt mit rechtsextremen strukturen
deutschland übernehmen und das ist sinn
und zweck dahinter und deswegen lautet
der vorwurf der bundesanwaltschaft eben
auch bildung einer terroristischen
vereinigung
das ist jetzt nur eine gruppe dieses
netzwerkes zeichnen
ein bild dessen r werder alles drin
steckt auch wie groß dieses netzwerk
deutschlandweit ist
ja man muss vielleicht einmal kurz
erklären es gibt ein netzwerk das gibt
es seit vielen jahren kommt aus
großbritannien blood and honour aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg von den neonazis gerne
übernommen blut und ehre und daraus
entstand ein bewaffneter arm kombat
eighteen 18 für die buchstaben des
alphabets für aha für adolf hitler und
diese gruppe war sehr aktiv sehr
aggressiv sehr gewaltbereit auch in
deutschland wurde dann verboten und dann
gab es immer wieder
nachfolgeorganisation heute morgen hat
die gsg 9 zum beispiel auch hier
nordrhein westfalen in castrop rauxel
die wohnungen von robin es bestimmt auch
ein ehemaliges mitglied von combat
eighteen der angeblich im hintergrund
das weitergeführt hat dazu muss man auch
noch sagen um zu sehen wie die
strukturen zusammenhängen dieser robin
es war der brief von beate schäfer der
mitglied des nsu und zum anderen gibt es
diese noch auf 51 das steht wiederum für
51a für eisenach dort gab es auch den
zugriff dort sind auch vier beschuldigte
mit haftbefehl festgenommen worden und
diese personen waren auf der einen seite
eine straßen schlägertruppe gleichzeitig
auch offenbar mitgliedern dieser
atomwaffen division und auch sie haben
bei corona demonstrationen wo man wieder
diese vermischung sieht auch polizisten
und gegendemonstranten angegriffen auch
teilweise verletzt und dazu kommt noch
dass ihr kampfsport training für diesen
kampf auf der straße angeblichen der
npd-zentrale ausgeübt haben und auch da
schließt sich wieder der kreis um zu
zeigen wie die strukturen so eng
vernetzt sind der npd-vorsitzende aus
thüringen thorsten heise wiederum war
auch immer eine bleibe in onna und
kompetent ein mitglied also das zeigt
die rechten strukturen es gibt viele
verschiedene strukturen viele
verschiedene gruppen aber am ende sind
sie alle jedenfalls die führungsfiguren
miteinander vernetzt frank schneider
chefreporter vielen herzlichen dank für
deine analyse